good day mates that that's not what they
say here
ahoy chips and fish what's up governor
oh but the governor doesn't live here
it's the queen we're at the queen's
house we're here in london
worth it one stop we're gonna do the
ultimate europe
travel experience this is my massive
bucket list item
traveling through europe by train what
type of trains are we taking here
we're going to be doing the url global
pass it's a
30-day pass you can go to as many
countries in europe as you want we're
going to take this a hyper speed
seven days seven countries it's more
like a seven stop
not a one-sided ah true we're in the uk
we're going to
belgium then the netherlands germany
czech republic then austria and then
we're gonna finally end
in italia verona home of romeo and
juliet
let's go tour the city all right how
much quid you got
you got quit i'm a footballer what a
[Music]
squid
we have big ben and little ben medium
ben
[Music]
i'm clarissa matus i'm the market
manager for north america for eureo
group
and it's a pleasure to have you here in
europe thank you so much thank you
what is your rail is euro a train
company
it's a rail pass we have like 35
railways and shipping lines and 28
countries so you have
europe in your hands europe and these
babies
it's not about one trip it's about the
travel date
you could take as much trains as you
wanted
in one day in 24 hours challenge
accepted bring it on europe
let's do it i don't want to fight europe
though when you purchase a
urea pass you receive a pest cover with
a ticket and the travel diary
you just put the date day and month
before boarding i just write it down and
it becomes true
yes magic let's go to brussels let's go
to brussels
we're going on a euro trip i've been
waiting my whole life for this
we're going to see so many things in
such a short span of time our brains are
not going to know
how to take it all in you are going to
visit seven countries and we are going
to travel in three kinds of trains
the first one is a high-speed train yes
it's the eurostar that connects
london to paris and brussels it's a very
comfortable train you have amenities you
have
meals and also very comfortable seats
dude this is so nice oh
these are the seats people in their
lairs sit in
with like a cat like a bald cat sitting
either a bald cat
or some kind of bird isn't that pirates
with a bird
oh yeah we're moving
bon voyage mateys so the cool thing
about this train is
it goes under water through the english
channel they call it the channel too
they called the
tunnel it's not a good word i don't like
the sound ah no
thank you thank you
cheers to europe this is the
first last meal cheers
you know we learned a plane fact once
when you're flying
you actually taste things differently
than when you're on land
now we get the real experience of food
at its proper elevation points
i mean all restaurants are at this
elevation too
yeah but we're traveling at 200 miles an
hour right now
you can't eat a meal like this when
you're driving or doing a road trip no
you can't
train fact choo choo in india some
trains use solar energy to power the
lighting and other systems that are on
board i like that why don't we do that
in the u.s
if we're going to talk about trains that
run on renewable energy
a lot of dutch trains run on wind energy
what
running a windmill for one hour allows
the train to travel 120 miles
double train fact this is the we're in
the tunnel we're in the tunnel
tunnel time tunnel
seamless transition into ben's bathroom
breakdown
let's go mirrors on mirrors on mirrors
you really check out your outfit
your standard toilet situation gotta
check the flush sound
it's not scary we got a hand dryer in
here
i'm giving this two big thumbs up one
two great job eurostar you're a star
there's something just so romantic about
the french countryside you know
kind of looks like ohio right now we
have about an hour left on the trip
i'm gonna just relax take a nap enjoy
the countryside
i'll see you in brussels
[Music]
now that's refreshing oh no
[Music]
do i look tough
[Music]
why are trains the best form of
transportation trains
are comfortable and your fun begins
while you are traveling
you have the landscape passing by and
you can connect
with the culture and connect with your
fellow travelers you can go to a bistro
car
have tasted german beer and when you
arrive you don't have to take any taxi
or any other
mode of transportation you are ready to
explore the city
so the train that you are going to
experience more in this trip
is the ice intercity express
comfortable see it's a lot of space for
yourself wi-fi
all right our train is here oh
yeah oh shoot
so many souvenirs we are on the train
let's talk about this comfortable
leather seats we are not
sharing an armrest which is huge
oh they got usb ports whoa which is
pretty crucial since none of my things
fit in the outlets here
for a train to hit the euro city
criteria which is what we're on now
it must travel through two or more
countries conductors must speak at least
two languages
there go my hopes of becoming a train
conductor in europe you wanna speak two
languages
i mean mason manos is this sufficient to
be like a train fact
train pack has anything about a train
train fan we are on a train okay yo i
got a train joke
that's good it's not one of your bend
masterpieces and i just came out with
another spot
what do you call an autotune artist in a
storm
i don't know what to right
can you believe i just came up with that
one yes
it's very comfortable and they all have
this trash bin right here just gonna
fill that with all your jokes
we got a nice menu to the prague life
cheers
i could hear them frying this up in the
back this wasn't like they just popped
it in the microwave they're actually
cooking this food here they have the
tools on a train it's like a food truck
yeah these have views look at that what
is that building
oh my god that is wow this
is the way to travel in a plane you
don't get to see
the views like this and you don't get to
eat like this
and i get carsick if i'm like reading or
focusing on anything close to me
nothing is sick about this train other
than the views
yeah all right let's go to prague
let's go
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
german
our final train and this is the one
i am the most excited for vienna to
verona to verona
yes this is a rail jet that is an
overnight strength i believe you're
sharing a cabin sleepover
our final train is going to be the obb
night jet it is a sleeper train
it does not come totally included with
the global pass that we got
we have to pay an additional 44 euros to
reserve this slaver train okay
all right let's get on this train
tonight jet
slime thank you you're welcome
yeah baby yeah okay we got
nice deluxe suite just so you know if
you're booking this in the future
your euro pass gives you a discount on
any seat on this train
we only get the best heater fan so
that's why i ride with you
whoa they got what they got juice for us
oh they know me they do beautiful
there we go oh what the [ __ ]
i thought it was juice applesauce
champagne from italia this is the
farthest thing from champagne
chairs cheers
i'm so ready for verona yeah i need some
good pasta in my life
look at these views wow dude i just want
to move to one of these gingerbread
houses
have a goat and just live off the land
oh yeah
beautiful rumor has it that there's a
shower in here
there's no rumor the rumors are true
let's go this is a first on ben's
bathroom breakdown we have
a shower on a train there's actually
plenty of room in here to get a good
shower
well done night jet one more important
thing we have to test the flush sound
is it terrifying
mild okay we still got action
i'm gonna take a shower now we'll see
how i do after
shower was awesome great water pressure
i'm giving this one
to a knee would give a second knee but
that flush was just
traumatizing oh we're in a tunnel
we're in a tunnel i am a funnel i like
to eat
okay no more tunnel look at this view
ben it's
so crazy this is stunning
wow i will say there's one drawback
but it can also be seen as a plus
there's no wi-fi on board
we need time to disconnect we're too
connected this train feels just like a
throwback to a different arrow
i'm just imagining mozart sitting here
composing on this window
seriously
i love tunnels okay it's over
let's pull the mattress down see what it
looks like go to bed and then we'll
woke up in the morning and talk about
how it was tunnel
is a time ah dang it i can't give that
the first purse
they do put this down for you if you
want but we want to kind of see how it
works so we're gonna just pull it
ourselves
oh nicely done ben
wow i'm gonna get in this bed
looking out at the viewfinder oh yeah oh
dude this is sick
this is the life man dude you have your
own bathroom to go to you not to walk by
all the other people
and honestly the train movement is
making me really tired
this bed is more than enough space for
me i'm six feet tall
and from head to toe i'm completely
covered
oh nice actually not right above oh wow
i did not see that coming
dude this is straight out of the movies
man i have always wanted to be
on a train like this i haven't had a
sleepover in
years get over here ben
i feel like i'm a kid again having a
sleepover yeah
this reminds me of me and my brother we
would play games at night we would just
tell stories my brother and i would
throw socks at each other
nope that is not happening tonight how's
the comfort level for you it's really
comfortable i can sleep in my
stomach you know what's crazy about this
we're knocking out both transportation
and hotel with
one go and it's cheaper than just
getting hotel by itself it's a hotel
on tracks how come you get the good view
though
oh dude you're gonna kill me do not do
that
bedtime
[Music]
ben yes we did it seven countries
in seven days we could have faked this
for the video
and like spaced it out over like three
weeks
we actually did a different country
every day
what an experience man that obd night
jet
pretty cool i didn't expect the train
tracks to be as soothing as they were
they kind of like rocked me to sleep
and the shower was really remarkable
top-notch shower
to italy to europe to europe
you